hi I'm Francesca and this is a story of
my first scientology audit I really went
in there what kind of an unopened mind
but also an informed mind so there's no
one at the front desk but there's a
front desk right there I was busy
looking at those sort of like
blockbuster video way in which all of l
ron Hubbard's books were laid out you
know just like Dianetics five shelves of
Dianetics be like the blue book the red
book the green book the red book in
Spanish there's a woman in the back and
she comes towards me and she's dressed
in all black and very smiley and says hi
can I help you there are 200 questions
to the personality test do you feel
stressed okay yes the third question is
do you find yourself reading trains
timetables and dictionaries just for fun
and then it'll be something like what do
you think about corporal punishment of a
child of 10 years old
[Music]
felt very 1984 in the way that their
different departments work so they
explained not what the religion is they
explained how it works it was an intro
into the common terminology that they
use there are things that happen to you
on your time track which I understood to
basically be your life that you know
sort of caused you pain so painful
memories they just called them engrams
that engrams are things that happen to
you at your childhood in your past the
goal of auditing and Dianetics is
essentially to relieve you of those
engrams and to release those engrams
we went into the basement of the
building we go through like three
different doors mega left right go in
and it says quiet auditing in session
room ten is right there it says out of
session she slips a little you know
placard and it immediately says in
session it's time it's like a closet
basically she had me close my eyes
pretty much immediately she says I want
you to think back to the earliest
painful memory that you have I thought
all right let's let's let's go softball
here so I talked about crying in my crib
after I finished telling her about it
she said okay no I want you to go back
and tell me again I went over and over
the memory and then she told me to go to
a pleasure moment I think is what she
called any time in my life of something
positive and I talked about being a kid
and eating oranges then at the end she
did was she said I'm gonna count down
from five and when I count down and then
I'm gonna say canceled and when it's
canceled it means it will no longer
affect you five four three two one
cancelled and I opened my eyes the whole
thing really felt like pop psychology it
is so vague I don't think anything was
clear to me and I don't think that's the
point what state would someone have to
be in to even come into the Church of
Scientology and then from there wanna
start taking a class where no one really
had explained to them anything when I
left I was like these I'm out you're not
gonna mess with my mom mm-hmm
that being said thank you to the Church
of Scientology of San Francisco for
showing me around
you were really hospitable and everyone
you know I wish you the best
I really wanted to ask about Xenu
[Music]